وبمناسبه الحديث على الانتخابات في موضوع
ثاني مهم عن الانتخابات ممكن نتكلم فيفا
حاليا مثل ما يكون شايف في يعني طبعا
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والتشريعيه التركيه
شغاله الحملات الانتخابيه للرئاسه
الامريكيه شغاله كمان والانتخابات منتظره
السنه الجايه هذه السنه في كمان
الانتخابات الروسيه الرئاسيه وغيرها يعني
الانتخابات عموما حول العالم ما توقف وفي
نفس الوقت مؤخرا الذكاء الاصطناعي صاير
موضوع رئيسي في كل المجالات مو بس
للمختصين بس كمان لعموم الناس اللي بدات
تاخد او تنتبه لهذا الموضوع وتركز فيه
وكاله اي بي نزلت تقرير امس بيدق ناقوس
الخطر وفي بتتكلم عن خطوره او خطوره ممكن
يشكلها الذكاء الاصطناعي على الانتخابات
تقرير اي بي بيقول انه الذكاء الاصطناعي
الان والديب فيك بتسهل فبركه الصور والصوت
والفيديوهات وممكن كده توصل للناس معلومات
غلط يبنوا عليها اصواتهم زي مثلا فيديو
مفبرك
او بيقول انه صوتوا لفلان مثلا او فيديو
مفبرك لمرشح بيعمل شيء سيء وهو ما عمله
هذه امثله لكن غير تقرير فيه هذا كمان في
كلام صاير عن خطوره مستقبليه او خطوره
مستقبليه للذكاء الاصطناعي على الانتخابات
في تزوير وفبركه الاصوات وانا ممكن بطريقه
ما تظهر اصوات لجهه او شخص او حزب ماء
وهذه الاصوات ما لها وجود في الحقيقه فمن
الاخر كده يعني نقدر نسال انه هل فعليا
الذكاء الاصطناعي خطر على الانتخابات
والديمقراطيه خلونا نحاول نجاوب على هذه
الاسئله مع ضيفنا المختص في التكنولوجيا
كريم تجربه شخصيه مع ستار مختصه في الذكاء
الاصطناعي اهلا فيك معانا
طيب خليني يعني ابتدي التقرير مقلق يعني
اصلا احنا كل الفتره الاخيره هذه كل شوي
بنسمع عن اشياء الذكاء الاصطناعي كانه
خلاص يعني حيجي ياكلنا يعني خلاص انتهينا
بسببه طيب هل ممكن نحن فعلا انه نلاقي انه
الناس مثلا
يعني خلاص تصويتات وهميه بسبب الذكاء
الاصطناعي الشخصيات امتحان شخصيات
بالتاكيد لان الذكاء الصناعي غير قادر حتى
اللحظه ان هو بينتحل شخصيه حد فيزيكال
يكون موجود بنفسه في اللجنه عشان يقدر فهو
ما فيش مستحيل يكون فيه تلاعب في
الانتخابات بشكل مباشر ان يحصل تزويق طبعا
انت الان بتعتمد على انه التصويت حاليا
لازم يكون انه شخصي يعني طيب اذا انتقلنا
لمرحله تانيه زي ما كل شيء في الدنيا جالس
بينتقل لمرحله انه لا نحن حنقدر نصوت مثلا
الكترونيا يعني في تقنيات كتير تقدر ان هي
تحمي عمليه التصويت من اي عمليه تزوير
ممكنه عن طريق توثيق هو الشخص بشكل
اذا كانت
التوثيق هيكون
التصويت هيكون ديجيتال ففي اليات كتير
تقدر من خلالها
الحكومات ان هي تحمي عمليه التصويت وعمليه
الانتخابات بالكامل ولكن الخوف اعتقد اكتر
هنا ان هو خوف من
التلاعب او التاثير على الناخبين ما قبل
عمليه الاقتراع وهنا ده الحوض
فيك الاشياء دي كلها ولكن الذكاء
الاصطناعي بقى له سنين بيتطور
كل العالم فدلوقتي ولقى ايه ده احنا عندنا
زكاه اصطناعي اعتقد اللحظه الفارقه عند
الناس كانت الشات جي بي تي
بس اعتقد قبلها يعني ما الناس حست انه
داخل في كل شيء في حياتنا اوردي الذكاء
الاصطناعي بالضبط موجود في كل حاجه موجود
في التليفونات تقدر على تليفون التليفون
كل شخص فينا في عدد لا نهائي من تطبيقات
الذكاء الاصطناعي من اول الصور اللي
بنشوفها وازاي بندور عليها لغايه الصوت
لغايه السماعه لما بنحطها في ودننا بيتم
تعديل الصوت بالذكاء الاصطناعي الذكاء
الاصطناعي مفيد جدا في كل حاجه احنا
بنعملها في حياتنا ومفيد لكل نقدر نقول
البيزنس مفيد لكل وسائل الاعلام مفيد لكل
الناس في مخاوف اه في مخاوف السوشيال
ميديا لما ابتدت كان محدش كان متخيل ان هي
هتغير شكل الاعلام هتخلي شركات هتخلي
مؤسسات اعلاميه عملاقه تفلس ومؤسسات ثانيه
قدرت ان هي تتطور بسرعه
وتواكب التغيير اللي بيحصل هنا اللي بيحصل
مع الذكاء الاصطناعي الحكومات والافراد
والمؤسسات قدامهم فرصه
لكنه غير مبدع ومش هيقدر يكون مبدع في اي
وقت قريب اوكي فبالتالي هو بيتبع اوامر
يعني يساعدك توفري بيننا بشكل عام الابداع
بشكل كبير جدا لان هو عنده ذاكره اقوى
كتير مننا ولكن احنا مبدعين هو مش مبدع
احنا قادرين ان احنا نفكر في زاويه مختلفه
ايه الدافع للابداع ايه التجارب اللي مر
بها لا ما عادي يا غزوه بتجارب الناس
يغزوه بتجارب الناس ولكن حتى اللحظه هو
غير مبدع غير قادر على حل مشكله ايجاد حل
جديد لان هو اسمه جينيريتيف اي اي جنريتيف
اي اي ببساطه هو ايه هو بيدرس الاحتمالات
وبيحط كلمات جنب بعض بدون تفكير فيها فهو
حتى اللحظه الذكاء الصناعي اللي كل الناس
خايفه منه هو ما بيفكرش هو مجرد بيرص
كلمات جنب بعض بناء على احتمالات
استخدامها من
افهم من كلامك انه حتى الان لازال البشر
هم اللي متحكمين في الذكاء الصناعي هم
اللي بيدخلوا البيانات بداخل هذا الزكاء
الاصطناعي فنحن زي اللي بنعطي له هذه
الامور بالضبط وهو ثاني غير قادر على
التفكير ما بيفكرش
ولان هو عنده ذاكره اقوى مننا لكنه مش
بيفكر يعني احنا طفينا السويتش خلاص
هينطفل سويتش بصفر
في كل حاجه الخوف منه هنا مثلا في مساله
الانتخابات باننا بنتكلم عنها لو ان في
الاليات الالات المستخدمه في عمليه
الانتخابيه متوصله بالانترنت هنا تقدري
تخافي منها لكن هي ما ينفعش تكون متوصله
بالانترنت فبالتالي مفيش تاثير للذكاء
الاصطناعي عليه طيب نحنا بنشكرك على هذه
المداخله كان معنا كريم فريد المختص في
التكنولوجيا شكرا لك
[موسيقى]